even before the pandemic the majority of
americans lived
paycheck to paycheck and when finances
are so tight it can be hard to think
about how you can save
extra money but today we're teaming up
with
chime to talk about getting on better
financial ground
and here to help us is money expert and
award-winning author
melissa leong
hi melissa i am so excited to be
speaking
about this with you and i'm going to
start off with this question
which is what is the first thing
that you should do if you're struggling
to save
money so
when you are feeling anxious or stressed
out about something it is
completely understandable to want to
just look away
from the dark and scary place you're
like i don't want to know
but i promise if you just turn the
lights on in your financial house and
take a look
that action is very powerful you need to
understand what's happening before you
can figure out
what you're going to do about it and so
i would download
print out all of my bank statements my
financial statements from the last say
three months
and see how much money has been coming
in and how much money is going out and
to where
you want to get an idea of your income
your expenses
categorize them i i'm old school so i do
it with a paper and a pen but you can do
with apps you can do with a spreadsheet
you're essentially creating a budget and
this will give you a better sense of
your situation
as you move forward i'm old school too
because i was picturing multiple color
highlighters
on that paper so what if someone decides
to
face it and then what they find is even
worse
than what they were trying to run away
from in the first place
so if you're brave enough to face it
first of all high five that's an
incredible feat for something that is
often very stressful for people
but once you do if you find that you are
in a situation where you don't have
enough money to pay for more things
beyond your essential needs
then you really only have two main
options make more money
or cut back so let's talk about cutting
back you know you've already created
this wonderful color-coded spreadsheet
with
your highlighters and your sticky notes
divide them into needs and once and then
go line by line
and figure out what you can cut and what
you can trim now when it comes to your
needs you can negotiate with your
service providers call them i just did
this with my insurance company i called
them i said it's the pandemic i'm not
commuting
and they lowered my premiums now when it
comes to your discretionary expenses
your wants
you can't meet you can't leave nothing
for fun right because
that is a recipe for a disaster but you
can agree have a conversation with
yourself and say you know what
for the next specific period of time i'm
just going to make some sacrifices
maybe that looks like cancelling or
pausing some subscriptions or
memberships maybe that looks like
a month of no spending so
only on essentials where you would spend
or maybe no spend mondays
wednesdays and fridays but whatever it
is that you cut you want to make sure
that you allocate that amount
to savings otherwise you'll just end up
spending it
on other things okay so your latest
paycheck comes in
what do you tackle first
well it can often feel like the money
comes in and then just
it's gone right especially if a lot of
your bills are automated
but again you've done this this budget
this spreadsheet
and you have a better idea of where
everything is going um
if your bills are not automated you want
to list them
and write them when they are due so that
you are not
well it sucks to waste money on late
fees for
missed payments right and so after you
take care of your necessities
the thing to focus on there are two
things debt repayment
and savings so when it comes to savings
no amount is too
little savings is a habit and so you
want to flex that muscle as much as
possible even if it's starting with a
small amount
and then setting a calendar reminder say
three months from now to bump that up
you want to download your bank app your
financial app to your phone so that it's
there you can be more mindful
of the inflow and outflow of your money
and you can also
try a tool like chime it's an
award-winning finance app and a debit
card with no service fees
you turn on your notifications and you
will get a notification
with every transaction and regular
balance updates
it's an easy way to help you stick to
your budget
what is your favorite money saving hacks
may i ask
so i am a busy sleep deprived
mom i cannot be relied upon to make
money smart choices
all the time and so i automate my
savings as much as possible
so actually chimes mission is to give
americans peace of mind
and they allow its members to
automatically transfer 10
of every direct deposit of 500 or more
into an optional savings account that is
an easy way to save money for your goals
it is
essentially putting your savings on
autopilot so when you put your savings
on autopilot what you also want to do
is you want to make sure that you're
having money come out say
twice a month on payday rather than
waiting until the end of the month
to see what is left waiting until the
end of the month
is like my husband asking me to save him
some chips
i'll just eat it all and then there'll
be no more
unless i set aside a handful of chips
for him before i start eating
so this is where you'll want to have
multiple streams of money coming out to
various goals so rainy day fund um
homeownership maybe retirement when it
comes to retirement if you have
a retirement plan with your employer
you'll want to maximize that especially
if they
match some of your or all of your
contributions that's like free money
and finally um we talked a little bit
about this how difficult it can be to
get motivated when it comes to money
and so this is the time where people
need to lean on their family and friends
you know according to research people
who had peer support actually saved
more money than those without it and so
find
well chosen people i mean not you know
the friends who peer pressure you to
spend money or encourage you to compete
but
people you can share your dreams with
you know someone you can say you don't
have to tell them how much you make or
how much debt you have but you can say
we're gonna check in every friday
together we're gonna do a fun money
challenge
and we'll talk about our goals you know
i have a group chat that i check in
um i check with them before i buy almost
anything actually and they're this
lovely non-judgmental
group who say mel you know this
virtual shoulder shake through the phone
you have other
goals that you want to save for you
probably don't need that do you
i think if we just talked more about
money with each other it would
empower us all i agree this is something
we cannot avoid
and that we need to figure out and i
think time
for the systems in which they're putting
into place to change people's lives and
i thank you
melissa leung for your incredible wise
wonderful sage
useful advice
[Music]
you